if you're an odesk contractor and you're
trying to win more jobs
i'm going to share with you the five
ways to wow
employers on odesk and land that job
hi i'm evan carmichael i believe in
entrepreneurs and i got a great question
from one of my youtube subscribers
albert
love you guys who wrote in to say hi
evan i'm about to start on odesk and
first i want to get all things ready i'm
a graphic designer and illustrator my
question is do employers get interested
on beginners
i mean i'm not a beginner but obviously
i would not have any feedback yet
because i'm starting it would be enough
with the skills and the tests to get
hired
albert albert fantastic question i'm a
huge supporter of odesk i've been an
employer there for a while
and i wanted to share with you my five
tips
for how you can stand out and wow
employers number one is write a great
bio what i look for in a bio it's not
just the skills you have but i want to
feel the passion for what you do
i want to know why you're doing what you
do and what excites you about it
so yes tell me your skills tell me where
you've worked tell me how many years
experience you have
but also tell me what makes you come
alive and why you do what you do
also make sure you get your bio checked
out by native english speakers so you
don't have errors in it
in your question to me you had a few
grammatical errors that
people don't care so much if you're a
graphic designer they're not hiring you
for your english skills
but every chance you have to impress a
client you want to take it so just get a
friend of yours who speaks english
fluently
to check out that bio and make sure
there are no mistakes
number two show you care about the
company one of the biggest pet peeves i
have with people who are applying for a
job for me on odesk or otherwise
is they do zero research into me and my
business
they just submit the form submit their
cover letter and fire it away
sometimes not even changing the name and
it's just saying dear sir or madam
if you want to stand out and really wow
the employer then do a little research
and digging into the business
visit my website and tell me what you
like about it follow me on social media
and respond to something that i've
posted
tell me what you really love about my
business and what attracts you to
working with me
i'd say only one percent of the people
who apply to a job
actually go that extra mile and i always
pay attention to those guys over
everybody else
number three is have a great picture
have a professional
full color picture of yourself that i
can clearly see your face and i can
relate to you
don't make your picture black and white
don't have a picture of you on the beach
don't have a picture of you in your
undershirt in your pajamas it's
professional you're trying to get a job
make it professional another thing i'd
say is make sure to smile in your
picture
i know a lot of people from different
cultures having a serious picture
serious face is is normal and standard
but if you want to work with north
americans we're used to seeing
smiling pictures for north american
employers
seeing somebody who's smiling makes us
relate to that person more makes us
like that person more and makes you more
likely to get a response from us
so have a great picture number four is
take the tests
so odess provides you all kinds of
different tasks that you can take to
showcase how great you are at different
software tools
this is especially important if you
don't have any work experience yet and
you're just getting started
you want to take those tests and it's
not just taking the test
it's doing well on the tests don't just
go into it saying yeah i know photoshop
will do that really well no problem
you need to score well you want to be in
the top 10 percent
of everybody on odesk was taking that
test so prepare for it
study for it and ace it because that
will really help make you stand out
versus everybody else on odesk and
number five is upload your portfolio
again this is super important if you
have zero work experience you want to be
able to show people that you have a
great portfolio and you know what you're
doing
i try to show a diverse range of
portfolio items
so that people know you can do a lot of
different things and as a bonus
if you really want to connect to the
north american employers
i try to have some north american
content in my portfolio
even if you've never actually worked
with a north american company before
just take a company and make a brochure
for them
because again as an employer if i'm
seeing something that i can relate to
that's in my language that is around the
company that i can understand
i'm much more likely to want to hire you
than if everything you have is in
another language on businesses that i
don't understand
so upload your portfolio and if you
don't have anything for a north american
company yet
create something so those are my five
tips write a great bio
show you care about the company have a
great picture
take the tests and upload your portfolio
and of course believe for those of you
watching i'd love for you to answer this
question
if you were considering hiring somebody
on odesk
and they had zero work experience that
they could share
there's their first contract what would
you look for what would you want to see
in somebody's response to you to get
them to wow you and make that memorable
leave that in the comments below i'd
love to hear what's on your mind and i
think others would really benefit from
it as well if you guys like this video
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and to the newsletter
thank you so much for watching and i'll
see you soon